the eyes in the brain don't perceive the
same world of color that the universe
creates
what we think of as color is like all
the other senses
just an approximation so that first way
of looking at things this is
going to be familiar to you this is the
electromagnetic spectrum colored light
is in one sense just the teensiest part
of the physics that surrounds them
and this sort of makes sense why it's
that narrow band because we're using
meat sensors to perceive it longer
wavelengths would cook
those meat sensors and shorter
wavelengths would ionize them into
little balls of cancer we humans call
anything between about 380 nanometers
and about 750 nanometers we call that
stretch visible light those are colors
to us
you can see here that the peak spectra
of the three of them that most human
beings have in their
eyes people call those red green and
blue or short medium and long
wavelengths but you can see that the
peaks aren't well distributed
the tails overlap this is like
everything else in our meat suits an
evolutionary cluj
and in some humans one or two of them
doesn't work
somewhere humans have a whole other one
of them in there in between the green
and the blue
they are tetrachromats as opposed to
most of us
trichromats um but the wavelengths it
responds to still fall inside the range
of what we
tend to call visible but look at this
birds birds are tetrachromats they see
colors way down into the ultraviolet
and bees they're trichromatic like us
but they don't even bother with red
they're seeing the green and the blue
and then ultraviolet the natural world
positively glows to these other animals
we can't even begin to imagine and we
can begin to imagine but we don't see
what they see
they have other colors and look at this
show off this is a mana shrimp 12
photoreceptors
into the uvn near infrared jerks i mean
now except for the colors out on the
edges
uh most scientists don't actually think
that the mantis shrimp
sees more colors than humans it might
not discriminate among a zillion where
we only do a kajillion or something like
that
it does do it faster the connections
between those receptors and what
what passes for a brain in a mantis
shrimp i'm not trying to be offensive
but you know
mantis shrimp but the point that i'm
trying to make here is that color is
quite literally in the eye of the
beholder what colors we see depend on
our
our biology